welcome everyone to another topic on
simply on chrome driver in which we are
going to talk about what exactly is
a kind of selenium chrome driver which
we are going to use
so let's get started with the very first
topic is what exactly is a chrome driver
now when we are working with selenium so
pretty much we
are going to use that tool for the
automatic test cases for the automation
of the test cases is what the
basis of the selenium tool here so if
you got a website
and uh let's suppose you want to log in
you want to
put some credentials you want to do some
transactions so if this kind of flow you
want to test it out
definitely having some back-end test
cases will not help you on that part
because they will not help you to click
on a particular
button put some imports in the input
text so it's it's more on like a dealing
with the more on the gui perspective
so that's where the selenium chrome
driver or the selenium comes into the
picture where it helps you to
drive those test cases where if you are
working on some kind of
gui uh related interface and you want to
test out that application so this kind
of functionality will be
helpful for you and how exactly it goes
on let's talk about the chrome driver
here
now chrome driver is a kind of a
component which is available in selenium
like you pretty much use chrome driver
only when you feel like
it's being utilized and at that moment
of time you are working on
uh the specific chrome driver and it
gives you a kind of a content here where
you feel like okay
i'm going to use this chrome driver to
see like how the implementation should
be done
and how the automation should be
performed over here
so chrome driver specifically helps you
to launches the uh
launch the google chrome browser if
you're going to use
firefox if you're going to use internet
explorer then they have their own
specific drivers
but this one means like all your test
cases is going to be executed on the
chrome browser
so if your application is compatible
with the chrome browser
then this particular driver makes more
sense for you
so it's kind of a driver like uh
definitely this web driver is going to
have all the api calls embedded inside
that
which is going to help you to automate
your web applications testing
so whether you want to go for chrome
driver you want to go for firefox you
want to go for internet explorer it
totally depends on the user
and your application's compatibility if
it's compatible with the chrome you can
pretty much use the chrome driver
without any issues
as such here right so why exactly we
need to use a chrome driver here
now when we are using a chrome driver so
it's basically
a kind of main component which is being
utilized by the selenium
by the selenium web driver because
selenium requires
a browser plugin or a browser driver
so that it can send the request so it
can send the request to the chrome and
it can process the request
uh if the selenium web driver is saying
like i want to hit onto some
input box i want to hit onto the summit
box so those kind of requests will be
processed by the chrome driver
so for that purpose we require the
chrome driver which will
only send the notifications or the
communications
which will be sent out to the chrome
browser with the help of the selenium
webdriver here
now it's being used to navigate between
web pages so
uh if you want to navigate or if you
want to go from one webpage to another
web page so for that also you can use
the chrome browser chrome driver here
so while doing the processing here what
you can do is like you can put the
inputs in the web pages like
let's say like you got a login page so
you can put up a username password
you can have the credentials not only
you can provide the credentials but you
can also click on some button certain
buttons like okay
let's click on the login button so if
you want to test out
how what will happen that if
automatically you're going to
click on the login button so how your
application is going to behave
so if this kind of a validation and this
kind of verification if you feel like
you want to do
then in that case these chrome browser
will be used by the selenium
to interact now the uh selenium
web driver or the selenium tool can
actually send the request and all these
requests will be processed by the chrome
dropper
so ultimately it's a chrome browser
where you will see the end results like
the website is getting navigated
the browser is getting closed
automatically the browser is getting
started or initialized automatically
here
so all that activity is going to be done
by the chrome driver which will in take
all the specific requests from the
selenium web driver here now let's see
like how we can
set up a chrome driver for this one you
require a chrome like
a chrome browser you need wire whatever
the platform you're using chrome is
pretty much installed there
if you already got a chrome browser
installed all you need to do is like you
need to get a
browser uh exe path over there so that
you can configure that into your
specific uh source code here so as a
chrome driver
in the configurations for that you can
put okay so this so and so location we
have the
exe file present there and the source
code can actually use it to
launch the chrome browser and do
whatever the activities
you want to perform on there as such
right so let's see like how we can set
up the chrome browser
uh and the chrome driver over here so
that we can run some couple of selenium
test cases
now for the chrome driver uh
demonstration over here we require four
things one
the cheddar installation the jre which
can be installed from the oracle
we already got the jdk installed into
our system and eclipse also installed
into our system so these two
prerequisites already being done
now chrome browser is something which is
also available over here we already got
the chrome browser embedded inside this
machine
so the only thing which is left out is
the selenium here because
pretty much though the jdk uh
eclipse and chrome browser you will
already be having it there onto your
development machines or into your
personal machines
if you're already dealing with the uh
disk with the java programming source
code
so you already have these things
available there but even if you don't
have these things we can easily download
those things and
configure into our machine so that we
can start using that one
right so we have the respective links
over here eclipse is pretty easy to
download just download the zip file
or exe file eclipse will be installed
and you can start using it
and in order to make the eclipse work
first you have to do the installation of
the
uh jdk or uh you know the java which you
want to install
so that that's what you require here
right so let's open the selenium browser
here so i'm going to click on this
button here
so this will help me to open the
selenium our website selenium.dev is the
website which is available there
which can help us to see like how we can
go ahead with this
particular selenium download here so we
are going to download the selenium here
and then we are going to utilize that uh
selenium over here in this one to
process it
so this is the selenium which we got
this is the website now here if you go
to the downloads like first of all you
got web driver
ide selenium gate these are the
different components which is there
now if you go to the downloads button so
here you will be able to see like all
the downloads which is available there
like
the browser or if you want to see like
the web driver
if you want to install so these are the
different uh programming languages
integrations which is available there
right so you can see like how the
executions
uh even if for the c sharp you have this
one here
so you also got the selenium id which is
available there
so all these different components are
available which you can see
which is easy for you to integrate for
the selenium here
right now since we are going to uh use
it for the java so we have got like uh
the
specific version over here three point
one point uh
for 141.59 here so this is something
which we can use
and uh you can also go for the beta
version also but i want to download the
uh stable version over here you can go
for the vital download also
right whatever version you feel so let's
go for the download option over here so
this will basically help me to download
a specific file as a file over here now
this zip file is something which is uh
going to have all the required values
and attributes which is available there
so let's see like what exactly is
available in this
file so this is kind of a selenium which
we are downloading and this is what we
are going to use in the eclipse also so
in the eclipse we will be using this
stuff
so that we can utilize it
so let's open this one here
okay now you got this uh specific
library files these are the different
library files which is a
required over here you can say like as
in dependencies
and these are the ones which is
available there these are the
uh executables like you can say like
these will help you to run
any kind of selenium test cases so all
you require to do is like you can just
indicate these ones into your class path
while running
your uh eclipse project you can add
these ones to the build path there and
this will surely work for you
these are the requirements like these
are the predictors which is required in
the eclipse
so that you can proceed further with
this one if these are not there
then it's going to show you the
compilations error so first we'll try to
put up the code base there
and see that what kind of error comes in
and then later on we'll see like how we
can
resolve those errors as such here so
let's go to the eclipse
right now what we really need to do is
like we need to create a new java
project and uh create a new class so
that's what we need to do
and in that case uh we have to configure
the build path but i'm not
going to add the external jars as of now
to put that
class bar there so what i'm going to do
is like i'm going to first
see there that how i can do that
installation so i i'm going to copy this
code here because this is what i'm going
to put up into my
a specific class so whatever the name of
the class you can give so here we are
using in the code base as in
the get started here so the same class
name we can use so that we don't get any
kind of issues
so let me copy this content
also uh provided like uh the driver the
chrome is already installed here so we
don't require so you can see here that
we are giving the path of the chrome
driver in case of linux platform when
you're trying to deploy it like when
you're trying to
put it up right there so in that case
probably you have to do the installation
like you have to download the chrome
driver for the linux platform
but here it's pretty much like you can
simply use it or you can
get it uh uh done because already the
windows platform we are using it
so we are launching the eclipse here so
uh in this one we will be creating a
quickly a class over here in this one
or kind of a project so that we will be
able to proceed further with that
so uh we're going to create an empty
project here in this case
so we got the uh specific eclipse opened
so we can go for a new java project here
so i can say it like selenium so we can
give any project name here
and we can say it like finish so there
will be some
basic structure which is available there
so i'm going to quickly create a
specific
file like a class file here now these
are the jar files which is available
like
white from the jdk but uh we can easily
go to the
build path and we can add the external
jars but we are not going to do that now
we are going to first see like what
error we are going to get
so i'm going to create a class here like
a simple class so getting uh
started is a class which i'm going to
create here because that's the one which
is available into my
content of the class file so you can uh
you know if you feel like you don't want
to use the same name like this one so
you want to use some different names so
you can easily do a rename
so that can be easily done there now
here the since
like the imports is something which is
coming up like this is not uh
something which is coming up over here
like it's not getting resolved
because of the fact that uh we are
pretty much using uh
the uh specific open uh the selenium
jar files the jr files but it's not
getting that it's not
showing that output here so let's see
like let's open the
uh specific downloads window here so
from where we can access these
jar files and we can refer it so we got
this one so let's extract this
completely uh you can put these uh for
jar files in any other locations if you
feel like you want to refer that so
you can keep put up into the default
location of the
eclipse also if you feel like this is
getting referenced
pretty much frequently and there are a
lot of projects that you are working so
in that case you can have it into a
small
folder or directly import it into the
eclipse itself
so here i'm just doing a one time
activity so let's
use this downloads folder itself from
where we can simply import these
jar files here so these are the jar
files which is available there
in the libraries we also got like an
additional jar file which is available
right
so we can go ahead with that part here
so these are the different libraries
which is available and these are again
the libraries
so let's uh you know change the build
path here so we'll go for the build path
here
and uh we'll say like uh we can add the
libraries here now libraries
is something which we want to sorry we
want to edit the
build path here
so here we're going to uh talk about the
external libraries like you know the
libraries which is available there
which we want to put up into this one so
we can say like add external jars
so now we can go for the downloads
button here and here we can put up this
jar file here now we also got a sources
one a sources jar file which is also
available there but what we have done is
like we have added only
the executable ones because sources ones
and executable ones
this is just the same the only thing is
that the sources one will have the
source code also we don't require that
as such
then lastly we comes up with the junit
one then of course like a junit uh
you know is also being referenced here
so for that we don't have to download
the jjured one because most of the
eclipse browsers are already having the
libraries integrated
so all you need to do is like you need
to click on the add library here
and we already got the j unit in this
one so we don't have to really go
anywhere there because it's a part of
the plugin of the eclipse that it's
already integrated there
in case of selenium you went for the add
external jar files and you added the jar
file there but not in this case
in june it will be automatically
referenced because of the fact that we
are using it on
over here in this case right so these
are the two references like junit also
we reference it because we are running
some
unit test cases here so which is like
already a part of the
uh plugins here in the eclipse yes uh if
you put the plugin of
the selenium and you integrate in the
same way then also you don't have to
go for this third-party references but
it's okay like you can
reference it there and you know any
project of selenium can work now because
you've got the basic
executables required for that so that
that's how it it works on there
right now we also have got like a
certain
other jar files which is uh which needs
to be added up over there
now those were not uh something which we
added because right now we
just resolve the issues related to the
selenium but uh these selenium
executables may also have some other
dependencies so for that what you need
to do is like you need to add
and another uh folder like uh you know
another uh
folder over here which is like lib here
so these jar files will also coming up
over here because
your code bases may be available or
maybe depending on these ones
so these are the exact uh you know
because your selenium may be dependent
on these jar files there so that's also
we are going to add up over here
so not only the client combined jar file
but other dependent jar files also is
going to be there into the referenced
libraries here
right now let's find out the executable
path of the chrome browser here so i'm
going to open the
c drive here because in that case we
will be having the chrome browser
installed
so it's a standard location where you
will be able to see your uh particular
chrome application exe file here
so uh pretty much this is the directory
structure which is available there like
in this one
it will be installed there so um you can
get the same
information from the chrome shortcut or
the from
a chrome icon also that where exactly
the exe file is referenced and if any
difference is there so you can do that
now this is a directory like this is the
exe file which is available there
so i'm going to just put that one over
here in this one
right so this is the way uh we are going
to put up the paths here in this ones
like how the
path should be referenced should be
executed over here and
uh ultimately uh this is required
because definitely when we are going to
run the test cases
uh this chrome browser will be sent the
notifications to opening www.google.com
here
and it's going to wait over there on
that part
and uh it's going to search the specific
keyword over here called chrome driver
so this is what
it's this program this basic program is
going to perform here
so now let's run the chrome browser here
so uh we're not going to run the chrome
browser but ultimately the
junit test cases so you right click over
here and say run as junit test cases
and this will ultimately help you to
launch a chrome browser
now i have not triggered it manually uh
i have
got it like automatically over here and
you can see like the cursor is going to
blink because it's
basically waiting for the selenium to
put up the inputs and all
now if you have the test case executed
like you open this website go to this
website
click on this and click on that so
according to that your browser will
start behaving
without any interaction from the human
there now this is a kind of a
functionality which we will get with the
selenium and this
makes easy for us like if we want to
validate or if we want to go through any
kind of web application waste
testing this is the ultimate way like
how we can go for that verifications
right so this is what we have in this
demo where we can see like how the
automatically we can do the chrome
browser we can interact with chrome
browser
right from the selenium over here so
let's go back to the main content
right so that was the way that how we
can configure the chrome driver with the
selenium here so that we can invoke
chrome browsers and when then we can
according to the statements we can start
sending the request
so that's uh pretty much which is there
now the various uh activities which we
did in this case was the jdk
installation
uh eclipse selenium a chrome browser now
chrome browser ide and jdk is pretty
easy to download and you can configure
it
and uh that that's the way that how we
can set up the chrome browser the main
important thing is like how to download
the selenium
and refer it into your projects okay so
that you can start using the selenium
over here
so that's it for this guys thanks
everyone bye bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here